now it's a trophy that pep guardiola has
won twice before but
never at manchester city winning the
champions league
has become a bit of a mission but thomas
tuchel his chelsea side
has beaten city twice this season has
something to prove himself having lost
in the final last year
when he was manager of psg let us go
live to porto and join former manchester
city player paul dickov
and former chelsea player pat nevin good
morning guys thank you for joining us
and paul i'm going to start with you um
city finished the season emphatically we
saw them lift the premier league trophy
you know which they
ran away with do they go into this match
as overwhelming favorites or just slight
favorites as thomas tuchel says
yeah i think they'll be slight favorites
jackie um you know obviously the end of
the season we're in the premier league
where they've been fantastic all year
and the best human the premier league by
a country mile but
obviously chelsea they'll be they'll be
hoping that the form against city
recently the fa cup semi-final and then
beating them the league
will hopefully have a bearing on it and
come tonight but i've just got a feeling
that
manchester city really want this tonight
you know and
um it's the one thing that's been
pointed at them over recent years as
there's not one in the champions league
not getting to the final of the
champions league and
you know the performance against
dortmund in the quarter final then
the performance against psg especially
in the semi-final
not just the way they played but the
desire they had not to lose that game
um is the reason why i believe that
they're going to as favorites tonight
pat what do you think i mean chelsea
beat city twice you know recently
including in
the fa cup semi-final but you know do
you worry about how they finished the
season because they sort of
fell away a bit didn't they
they did in terms of results but only in
terms of results they were
they continued to play exactly the same
way they just
didn't get the same amount of luck they
don't give many opportunities away but
those
three or four goals they give away at
the end of the season they were either
as we say in the game
worldies or else they were you know
flicks against them so
they will they would take a lot of heart
i mean this school but marcus alonso
would
give chelsea that win but they will also
be realistic about it
i don't think city put their best team
out in either of those games so
it gives a little bit of a fill up a
little bit of a lift
but i'm very much with paul in this one
there is no doubt that manchester
city are slight favorites but that also
slightly takes the pressure off chelsea
they're ahead someone said to me they're
two years ahead of where they would be
expected to be
at this point two about four or five
years ahead would they expect to be
purely because this is thomas tickle
halfway into a season so he's done well
to get this far
and he'll just hope to have a great day
on the day yeah he won't be just
thinking he's making up the numbers
though will he um
how important is it paul that the city
players don't make this
too big a deal make this match too
important because
you know one of the headlines in the
papers today is you know it's the holy
grail
but you know one mistake wanting it too
much can also be a bad thing can't it
yeah it is but i also think jackie that
they'll learn from from recent seasons
you know
a couple years ago when they were out
against liverpool and then against
tottenham
you know and then last season especially
against leon you know
there were overwhelming favorites in
that game but the disappointment of that
is the thing that's really driving them
on um you know the leon game there's a
couple of individual errors
and if you look back to liverpool and
then the tottenham game as well you know
defensively city work the best but
that's
that's where it's turned around this
season you know everybody looks at
manchester city looks at the kevin de
bruyne as the phil fodens the
mahrez the bernardo silva and talk about
the wonderful players i've got but
defensively this season they've been
outstanding you know with edison and
goal
ruben diaz john stones and and having
that
the comfort of knowing how good they are
defensively is the reason why i don't
think they'll go into
um with any nerves or at the same time
being overly confident
because they know that if they defend
properly if they cut
chelsea down to the maximum chances that
they're going to get with the players or
just spoke about going forward you know
that they can beat any team in the world
and
you know you go back to the dortmund
game where early holland was scoring
goals for fun they managed to keep him
quiet psg
with mbappe and neymar you know they're
limited to to limited chances in the
game
and i think that's where it's going to
be done tonight because chelsea under
thomas took over they've been fantastic
since
you know they're very very well
organized um
very good defensively but very very good
on the break as well that the pace have
got up front so
city will be worried about it but
they've just got to be careful as you
say that they don't
um that the nerves don't kick in and
they just go out and play as manchester
city do and
if manchester city plays well as they
can tonight and chelsea play as well as
they can if i fully expect manchester
city to win but
it's a one-off game um and you know
they're usually decided by
big games by either refereeing decisions
or
definitely the team that makes the list
the least mistakes in the game yeah
absolutely and pat the fact that these
two teams know each other so well
you know is that a blessing or is it a
curse could they cancel each other out
do you think
well that happens regularly i remember
going to
the champions league final when it was
chelsea versus manchester united's over
in moscow
and there was definitely a bit of that
and the two league teams known each
other that well but
you have to deal with it you mean i
suppose you only play each other two or
three times a season so you know reach
out fairly well but not
that well um but i still think it'll be
a good game to for it to be a
special special game that you know that
everybody can enjoy not just chelsea man
city fans
you probably do need an early goal and
if it was an early goal for chelsea
that would almost make chelsea defend so
you almost want
an early goal for manchester city so
that chelsea come out and then you get
a much more free-flowing game but you
know whatever it is
tension will definitely be there and i'm
looking forward to it it was interesting
listening to paul there
and seeing all the positives and he's
right about manchester city
but of course there was one line that
you paul did say there about chelsea and
it's the giveaway line
it's the pace up front that chelsea have
got and chelsea's pace up front
they're not great scorers but the pace
is actually quite scary isn't it paul
and and that's the thing that's really
got to me that
the goals that you've scored against
manchester city this season
they've scored in that area however the
one player i expect to be in
right away from the start for city is
walker at right back because
his pace defensively may well cut off
the one line
the one hope that chelsea have got of
scoring but uh
they'll try and find another way and it
might actually take all the way to
penalty kicks
oh you know what i can just so see that
happening now we're really
almost out of time um i just wanted to
ask either one of you actually
i'll ask paul you know do you think this
game should have been played in england
given the circumstances
given coverage you've got two english
teams what on earth are they doing
flying all the way to portugal and
all those fans flying as well should it
have been here
yeah i'm not complaining jackie cause
i've got to get to portugal i'm getting
this on for a few days so um
but but not all seriousness it would
have been fantastic if it was in england
at wembley you know we would have been
able to have more fans there
and obviously it would have made so much
sense you know chelsea fans manchester
city fans and
in their thousands and it just would
have been a great atmosphere and a great
spectacle but
i've got to say the atmosphere here in
porto with the chelsea fans and
manchester city fans and last night and
this morning it has been fantastic but
i do agree with you jack it would have
been fantastic if it was at wembley with
more fans in there
and obviously saves all the the hassle
of the travel and
and the expense of people having to get
here as well yeah absolutely we're out
of time so just very quick predictions
paul first of all
i think it's going to be a tight game
i'm going to go manchester city 2-1
although he wouldn't expect me to say
anything less
no absolutely not pat what do you think
disappoint you massively by saying i
think you have nil now 1-1
all the way to penalties and chelsea are
not bad at penalties so i'll go for
chelsea
but only on penalties afterwards one
word about uefa
they are a huge disappointment for not
moving the game they've really let
themselves down
and they've let the fans down badly for
not playing in the uk
i'm very disappointed in them okay um
guys thank you so much you know have a
great day enjoy it i'm sure you're going
to really enjoy it
um i'm not sure it's a match that
players can really enjoy it's almost
something just to get through i think
isn't it and thank you very much but
sixteen and a half thousand fans in that
stadium it's almost like sport is
getting back to normal almost you know